original
nous les originaux dans One World original
avec le pouvoir de la
musique
J nous les originaux dans One Love
original avec le pouvoir de la
musique
J
nous les originaux dans One Love original
avec le pouvoir de la
musique ch
nous les originaux dans One Love original
avec le pouvoir  de
la musique,
ne me fais pas perdre mon meilleur côté,
n'est-ce pas à propos de ce que j'ai à
l'intérieur, seulement du vrai original, je n'ai pas besoin de
mots, seulement du vrai original, bien, vois ce
monde, devrais-je te faire sentir bien à l'intérieur
sur la musique, continue  mon
côté est seulement original car cela fonctionne seulement un vrai
original peut voir ce
mot nous les gens originaux dans One World
original avec le pouvoir de la musique
J nous les gens originaux dans One Love
original avec le pouvoir de la
musique
CH nous les gens originaux dans One World
original avec le pouvoir de
musique
J nous les gens originaux de One Love
original avec le pouvoir de la
musique
J nous les
gens originaux de One World original
avec le pouvoir de la
musique nous les gens originaux de One Love
original avec le pouvoir de la
musique
CH nous les gens originaux de One World
original avec le pouvoir  de la
musique
J G nous sommes des gens originaux dans One Love
original avec le pouvoir de la
musique